Have you ever heard the phrase "bite off more than you can chew?"
When you "bite off more than you can chew"...
...that means that you try to do too much...
...or you try to do something too difficult for you.
For example, "I always bite off more than I can chew when I accept all those projects."
In other words, I try to do something that is too much or too difficult for me.
Let's check out the next few clips to learn and practice how to use this idiom.
By purchasing that huge new house,...
...John has bitten off way more than he can chew.
You might say "don't bite off more than you can chew"...
...because you might not be able to do either of your jobs properly.
So don't take on any crazy projects that are...
...don't bite off more than you can chew.